remember gopro the insanely popular
action camera brand that blew up in 2014
and 2015
gopro introduced a simple yet
revolutionary way to share crazy
adventures whether that be surfing
skydiving or scuba diving gopro's small
and durable cameras were perfect for a
wide range of activities and even caught
on within the vlogging space
even today gopros remain rather popular
amongst adrenaline junkies and vloggers
however the same cannot be said about
investors
when gopro ipod in 2014 investors piled
in and bid up the stock over 100 in a
matter of months but ever since the
initial hype died off gopro stock has
just been selling off and it even became
a penny stock for a few years trading
under five dollars a share
gopro has recovered a little over the
past year to about nine dollars a share
but that's still 75 less than the ipo
price and 90 lower than their peak so
what happened to gopro
well taking a look back gopro was
actually founded quite a while before
they blew up in 2002. the story goes
that nick woodman the founder of gopro
went on a trip to australia and
indonesia in 2002 during the trip nick
went surfing and he wanted to record
himself so he got a 35 millimeter camera
and attached it to his hand using a
rubber band
as you would guess this was not a very
effective solution and much to nick's
disappointment there weren't many
solutions on the market you either had
to record from the shore which largely
deprived the support of its intensity or
you had to buy expensive waterproof
cameras so nick decided to create his
own solution he used his mom sewing
machine to develop a camera strap that
wrapped around his body he also created
a wrist strap that could attach the
camera to his arm nick strongly believed
that there was a large group of sports
enthusiasts who also wanted to capture
their experiences so he decided to
launch gopro in 2002 the name comes from
the idea that users of gopro cameras
could capture footage like the
professionals fortunately for nick his
father dean was a baller himself dean
was the co-founder of an investment bank
named robertson stevens which manages
1.5 billion assets today so nick was
able to borrow 200 000 from his father
to kickstart gopro with the funding
secured nick worked with the chinese
company called hotex to create a 35
millimeter camera using nick's wrist
strap the company was able to produce
the cameras for just three dollars and
five cents and the nick would turn
around and sell the cameras for thirty
dollars
nick originally saw the cameras from his
1971 volkswagen bus however it didn't
take long for nick to hit his first big
order in 2004 nick was able to sell 100
cameras to a japanese sports company and
the following year he would make an
appearance on qbc
this substantially boosted his sales and
the nick would close 2005 with 350 000
in annual revenue over the next several
years nick continued to strike deals
with sports companies and he continued
to aggressively market the product
gopro's revenue was doubling on an
annual basis and by the early 2010s
gopro was generating over 100 million
dollars in annual revenue and this is
when gopro would break out from being an
up-and-coming startup to being a
multi-billion dollar corporation at the
end of 2012 the taiwanese manufacturing
company foxconn made a private
investment into gopro they purchased
8.88 of the company for a whopping 200
million dollars which valued gopro at
2.25 billion at the time nick owned over
50 percent of the company which made him
a billionaire nick would take the
company public a few years later in 2014
and as we previously touched on the
stock exploded gopro peaked at a
valuation of over 10 billion dollars
moving forward in 2015 nick scored a
partnership with the nhl and he would
even be invited to shark tank as a guest
shark he actually made two investments
on shark tank for a total of 125
thousand dollars
but the truth is nick was in no position
to help other companies grow given that
gopro itself was undergoing an internal
crisis
but wait a minute didn't gopro just have
an insane ipo and a major partnership
deal what went wrong
well the answer isn't some sort of
pinpointable event rather it was years
of complacency and missteps that slowly
ate up the company probably the biggest
red flag for gopro was that nick was way
in over himself for example in 2014 nick
was the highest paid u.s executive
earning a total of 285 million dollars
now i know a lot of you guys think that
that's way too much for any executive to
earn whether that be nick or tim cook
but the key difference between apple pay
such a salary and gopro paying such a
celery is that apple can actually afford
it in the last 12 months apple has
profited 86 billion dollars
so paying a 200 million salary is less
than a quarter percent of their net
profit in other words it doesn't affect
the company's balance sheet whatsoever
with the gopro on the other hand they
weren't profiting billions or even
hundreds of millions
the year that nick made over a quarter
billion dollars gopro only made 128
million that's roughly equivalent to
apple paying tim cook 60 billion dollars
per year
i don't think i need to explain why this
is an issue that same year nick bought a
180-foot yacht a gulfstream jet two
mansions and a collection of vintage
sports cars
nick also donated 500 million to charity
which is awesome but this donation was
also infamous for being a tax loophole
you see nick was technically supposed to
wait 180 days after the ipo before
selling any of his stock
but given that gopro went public in the
second half of 2014 nick wouldn't be
able to sell any of his talk till 2015.
however as we touched on it nick had
already spent a lot of money in 2014 and
having a tax write-off would be awfully
helpful so he donated 500 million
dollars in october of 2014.
again nick was technically not supposed
to do this and this made many investors
quite angry but no one took any action
because that would just make themselves
look bad i mean if you sued to stop nick
from making the donation you would be
the bad guy preventing a half billion
donation
so no one stopped him and this donation
allowed him to write off 450 million
dollars and avoid capital gains taxes on
the stock he sold
now i honestly have no problem with an
exploration or donating whatever he
wants the problem is that gopro simply
wasn't large enough to support this type
of lifestyle as nick's personal
lifestyle inflated so did the
operational costs of gopro nick went on
a hiring frenzy and expanded into every
sector he could think of
in the 8 months following the ipo
gopro's employee count ballooned from
700 employees to over 1600 employees
similarly the budgets for marketing
campaigns photo shoots and basically
everything else went through the roof
gopro's creative director says that
budgets across the company increased
tenfold during this time period
as gopro's operational costs exploded
the company's bottom line got crushed
between the third and fourth quarter of
2015 gopro's bottom line fell off a
cliff from 180 million dollars in the
past 12 months to 37 million dollars
from there it didn't take long for gopro
to start losing money and by 2015 gopro
was burning over 400 million dollars per
year
since then nick has actually been
extremely transparent about his reckless
spending and the downfall of gopro
aside from his spending habits he's
offered four additional reasons behind
the fall of gopro starting with living
in the future
nick says that he hyped up future
products and projects way too much it's
great to be excited about the future but
this turns into a problem when all of
your employees and investors become
fixated on the future employees start to
lose focus on making current products as
good as possible and a perfect example
of this was the hero 5 black as gopro
was attacking drones and entertainment
head-on they slipped up on their core
offering the hero 5 black received
several complaints that it was leaking
underwater and it turned out that gopro
had a production issue having to fix the
production issue prevented them from
reaching their production goal for the
holiday season which put them in an even
bigger hole the second lesson that nick
describes is that being great at one
thing doesn't mean that you're great at
everything
likely one of gopro's biggest blunders
was trying to expand way too quickly and
the best example of this was their drone
lineup in 2015 and 2016 the popularity
of drones was going to the moon and
given that the cameras on drones was one
of their biggest selling points it
seemed like creating a drone was right
up gopro's alley in late 2016 gopro
launched a drone called the karma karma
was hyped up quite a bit and many
thought that karma would give gopro the
boost they needed but the launch turned
out to be a disaster many reviewers and
users started to complain that the
drones were losing power mid-flight and
literally falling from the sky
on the bright side nick didn't play any
games when it came to this issue he took
it super seriously and recalled the
drone just a few hours later
while this was the right thing to do
this of course devastated the company
and the gopro wouldn't have been in that
situation if nick didn't try to expand
it too quickly moving on to the next
third lesson we have stick to what you
feel most strongly about amongst the
gopro's expansion frenzy one of the
sectors gopro targeted was entertainment
for some reason gopro invested heavily
into producing their own shows
this included a travel show called
beyond places a family show called kids
save the world and a reality show about
new york city motorcycle cops all of
these shows were slated to release on a
new streaming platform the gopro was
developing but as the company started to
lose money nick realized that he didn't
actually care about these shows or the
streaming platform these were simply a
business expansion move as opposed to
something he was actually passionate
about so he killed the projects and
diverted the money back to the core
business and that brings us to next
final and likely most important lesson
which is that simpler is better
throughout gopro's entire rise and fall
it seems like they're consistently
trying to be something that they're not
they're not a drone business they're not
a media business and they're not a giant
conglomerate who needs thousands of
employees what made gopro successful was
being a niche camera business that
appealed to action seekers and vloggers
and for so many years gopro had
completely ditched this market as they
tried to expand their audience at the
rate gopro was going it wouldn't have
been surprising if they went bankrupt
but it looks like nick is pulling
through it at the last second he is not
trying to defend how he led the company
or making any excuses he admits that he
was wrong and that he would like to
return to what made gopro great he
heavily reduced the workforce he
eliminated the unnecessary expansion
programs and he's become much more
mindful of his spending all of these
steps seem to be working as gopro's net
losses have not only been improving but
gopro just announced their very first
positive 12 month period since 2015.
maybe gopro's return to glory is just
around the corner but only time will
tell
do you guys think gopro can make a
comeback comment that down below
also drop like if you respect nick's
willingness to own up to his mistake and
of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one